Tenemos cinco números por aquí, y la idea es
ordenarlos de menor a mayor. Puede que sea obvio
para ti que estos cinco números son negativos,
entonces concentrémonos en cuál de estos números
es el mayor. Y tal vez te sentirás tentado a
decir "Bueno, si estos fueran números positivos,
entonces 40 sería el mayor", entonces podrías
pensar que -40 es el mayor. Pero ten cuidado,
debes pensar en lo que nos dice el signo
negativo. Piensa un poco, imagina que
estas fueran cantidades de dinero en tu cuenta de
banco, ¿preferirías tener -40 dólares o -7 dólares
en tu cuenta de banco? Menos 40 significa que le
debes 40 dólares al banco, es no tener nada -40;
-7 significa que sólo le debes 7 dólares al banco,
entonces -40 es menor que -7, de todos estos
números es el menor. Entonces, -40 es el menor,
y podemos verlo como la menor cantidad de dinero:
puede haber en tu cuenta bancaria la cantidad
más pequeña, le debes al banco o 40 dólares,
no solamente no tienes nada, además le debes al
banco o 40 dólares. Después, el siguiente número
más pequeño es -30, luego el número más pequeño
que le sigue es -25 y el que le sigue es -10 y
finalmente el mayor de todos estos números es -7.
Y si no te resulta obvio, puedes pensar todo esto
en términos de temperatura. ¿Cuál de todas estas
temperaturas es la más fría, independientemente
de que estemos hablando de grados Celsius o
Fahrenheit? Menos 40 sería la temperatura más
fría y -7 sería la más caliente. Hay más calor
en el aire a una temperatura de -7. Otra forma de
verlo es dibujar una recta numérica. Si este es el
0, y podríamos poner +7 por aquí -aunque sabemos
que no es uno de estos números que queremos
ordenar-, entonces este de aquí debe de ser -7,
y si éste es -7, entonces este de aquí debe de ser
-10. Observa cómo vamos cada vez más y más lejos
a la izquierda de 0, y luego nos vamos un poco más
a la izquierda y llegamos a -25, un poco más lejos
a la izquierda y llegamos a -30, y todavía
un poco más lejos a la izquierda y llegamos
al -40. Si lo piensas de esta manera, el menor
de estos números es el que está más lejos a la
izquierda en nuestra recta numérica, mientras que
el mayor es el que está más lejos a la derecha.